take it to the next level and be an
elite nba player
it's a bonus pushing his way to the rim
and oh
wow where the left hand slam high post
area or around the floor and just
look at that he's setting screens if
[Applause]
trying to win it the aaron fox rejected
by miles
turner stepping in knocking it down and
then miles turner on the other end
right the aaron fox very close to
getting an offensive foul there
miles turner saved it now it went out of
bounds the officials may look at this
with you know the entire uh opportunity
to listen to utah
you two guys and just hear how she
understands
the global factory of the game
tough one here but a solid play if you
look at tj warren not normally known for
making that kind of play
but through traffic he delivers it he's
the lone pacer in double figures rose
has 13
drummond has 10 and 10. and that's
blocked by turner
took pass that was a tough pass
but it's picked up by brogden and
sabonis lays it in
lamb has the size advantage against
graham
oh my goodness what a heck of a move
ladies and gentlemen
that's the 360 he just made watch this
he just the 360 in the air partner 84.81
pacers
lead by three sabonis pounds it down but
this is aaron holliday's player
it's in holiday real good read there by
holiday to know
that and coming to the middle you're
gonna get howard in a strong finish by
dominic
[Music]
so the pacers have a seven-point lead
some bonus oh yeah
yes he got him on that one embiid's down
here but
pal took that lesson is this
the dunk of the decade
[Applause]
on a 17-2 run they outscored
philadelphia 38-16 in the second and put
it away
sabonis down the lane with authority
he says basketball that is best open man
gets the ball you play with power
and strength big fella what's the right
thing to do
you get it in the middle
[Music]
sampson got the start he pounds it down
he's got by marketing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he is showing off getting great passes
[Applause]
[Music]
brogden gets around
[Applause]
just a outstanding job reading the
opportunity and trying to take advantage
of it
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah he caught draymond green on the
reach and miles
got to the right one of the rare uh
bright spots here early the dunk by
miles turner
slow start for the blue and gold
decision by warren oladipo 4-3
yeah jacob sampson coming out of the
left corner with that
he's coming out of the corner on the
right and is able to get a strong finish
nobody put a body up no one put a body
on it
so he's able to get it and he's got to
feel good that way a matter of fact he's
flexing
coming out of that you know he feels
good besides felicio
it's 6-7 now hold the depot has it
hutcheson here's a long three by one
yeah
he's back he's back
ladies and gentlemen approved you know
what
the real key to being a klutz player is
being willing to take what comes with it
it's no good but holiday the rebound
it's wrestled away picked up by
mcconnell
great fine with a no look
tj is he's able to do a great job see
the opening there
morris had him more senior had him in
morris
blocked in the rebound thirty eight pass
count five
[Applause]
you'll see i mean he tries to foul it
and sabonis makes the play there oh
that's a foul every day
all day every day another eight point
lead for the dallas mavericks with 7.6
and oladipo a long three
good to get the fans into the game a
little bit here chris
the raptors appear to be putting another
one in the win
column so bonus and one
on the foul on and ob turn this thing
around for the pacers what did i tell
you about using big words
like that but great the end of the third
quarter and the pacers had
55 points yeah it was chris it was just
an ugly ugly
evening although he got another one
in terms of watching martin try to get
to the rim
turner protects for his sixth block able
to do it cleanly
[Applause]
miles turner has played 11 minutes in a
minute of the first half
and
[Music]
look how quickly these guys get the ball
up the court an excellent read there
by sumner to see running jakar sampson
getting another one of those dunks you
talked about the four you had the last
time
30-point games before the all-star break
he had 41 against the clippers
as sabonis sneaks through the lane he's